Hey, it's been a while since we heard from
a furious Trump is Jimmy from Philly.
I know some people in the audience love hearing
from Jimmy from Philly.
Some people, people in the audience have said,
David, please no more Jimmy from Philly.
We don't want to hear it at all.
Uh, we have heard from Jimmy from Philly and
he is furious at soy boy's sick offense and
continues to seem to misunderstand how some
online social platforms work.
Take a listen to this.
David.
Jimmy from Philly.
Yeah, I just got banned on Facebook because
one of your little soy boy sycophant rich
Lewis, we pointed me to Facebook, right?
What a joke.
Trump 2020 because you again,
listen, we don't even have moderators on Facebook.
We don't, we don't do, we don't touch Facebook
at all.
So as usual, if Jimmy is getting banned from
these platforms, it's because Facebook is
determining that he's violating some kind
of community standards.
And when you hear the mouth on this guy, does
it shock anybody to think that what he's posting
to social media might realistically get people
banned or blocked from these platforms?
Jimmy, I'm sorry, we haven't had a chance
to speak live during live calls, but it's
good to hear from you in a sense and a still
very, very furious.
We've got a great bonus.
So for you today we are going to talk about
the Cleveland police officer who urinated
on a girl as she waited for the bus.
He has been sentenced to four and a half years
in prison.
We will also talk about China's birth rate
hitting the lowest in modern history.
This is an interesting economic story.
It's an interesting political story.
The China birth rate a, um, story actually
relates to a lot of different issues that
are important if you're just an observer of
what's going on in the world.
Also tool, see Gabard has endorsed legalizing
drugs.
We will discuss all of those stories and more
on the bonus show.
Two ways to get instant access.
Become a member@jointpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David pack.
Phil will speak to you that the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.